so earlier you were talking about you
know completing anime completing shows
just
yeah yeah just just so you can put it on
like your list or whatever yeah so would
you like
have you ever like watched anime or
shows at like 1.5 speed or two-time
speed absolutely not
that's good that's tough okay good yeah
any of you do that no no no you're not
psychopaths yeah do people do that i've
done that i've done that i've brought or
won that
for what show huh
you can do it for brotherhood
i've actually done it for like a lot of
shows most mostly mostly so
because it is my job right so i have to
let this release
because
i do it and it's better you drop the
episode or you watch it in 1.5
there are some okay there are some shows
there are some shows where you're just
like i i i kind of like i know what kind
of show this is going to be but i need
to consume it in order to like review it
right
and
and so instead of watching it at normal
speed i'm just like just to make sure
i'm going to watch this show at 1.5 or 2
speed just to make sure that it's
actually the show that i think it's
going to be and 99 percent so they're
all like
probably like that
you have no idea how quickly i can read
subtitles now because of this right like
i literally like it's osmosis right now
whenever i watch subtitles it's
[Laughter]
sheer disbelief
what why did i agree to be on this
someone's watching this at one point
oh god have you watched any like any
youtube videos at one point five speed
are you just like yeah i'm a firm
believer that you shouldn't watch videos
in the one point five streams i can't i
physically can't there are occasionally
some youtubers you can you're just not
trying hard enough there are some
youtubers when you put them to 1.5 they
sound like they're talking at a normal
speed yeah which is that's when i need
it yeah because i'm like please i need
you to oh actually no there there is one
youtuber that is a friend of ours that i
watch at 1.5 speed uh sorry john a super
match
but you know but you just talk so slow
dude
but like john john's someone who i ca
like i
you need to watch at normal speed
because like his his pace like it it
brings like the immersion and the mood
he's trying to set yeah but you
shouldn't brutalize but something but
sometimes i'm just like what else is
something you need to watch at its own
pace all things
i don't deal with every john video but
like sometimes where he drops like he's
like
when he's like 50 minute like videos i'm
just like
i really want to watch it but i just
don't have the time right now so i'll
just i'll just like i'll do 1.25 you
know just like a little bit faster so i
can just get it through it a little bit
faster i am the type of person where if
i'm what listening like someone let's
say someone's put like puts up like a
song from a movie or something yeah yeah
and it's even so slightly
because sometimes it's pitched wrong
because it's like
either for copyright or something like
just it's like one half note because of
the speed yeah i'm like i can't watch
this
it distracts me so much yes this is not
right this isn't right yeah yeah 1.5 or
two times
no i've never seen a person look more
disgusting please never even
say that to me what are you you're going
to say something next to piss me off
what's next
yeah i mean like are you the type of guy
where you watch something and you need
to like i kind of like
how can i say this you can't
can you watch something casually like in
the background or do you need to be like
sitting down paying attention making
sure that you are in like the mood and
the zone into i have to be watching full
attention because i'm the same yeah
because i have a lot of friends in the
animation industry right and they're
like i watched this show while doing you
know drawing or doing work and yeah so
you didn't watch it then
so you didn't really watch it you heard
a podcast version of it yeah like i i
get like doing that with like music for
example exactly right because it's like
you know it's there's nothing visual
you're only just using your styles
but like you know or like with music
videos for example right but it's like
with something like a movie or a tv
series especially when it's anime where
it's like you know subbed for instance
yeah you have to watch it fully because
it's a visual show like it's it's yeah
exactly again you're just watching the
podcast version yeah like a podcast i
can listen to while i'm doing something
that's what it's for right yeah but yeah
if you say you watched a show
and you were doing something else the
entire time yeah i'm like okay so you
you didn't really so you didn't watch it
yeah but now i'm like would i rather
someone watch a show half paying
attention or through double speed
i don't know what's worse
we found the bigger evil
i don't know so in double speed
yeah
you're watching it entirely though
no you're you're not no no okay okay i
am watching inside you're also doing
something no no no no no no no no no i i
can't do that i can't do that i can't do
that like if
the reason i put it on 1.5 or two times
speed is because i cannot watch
something casually like i would love to
be able to you know watch anime and be
able to like write about it um stuff my
job and also be able to like do
something else especially if it's like a
[ __ ] show but like i'm the type of guy
who who needs to pay attention and i
need to be watching it but sometimes
there are just there's like a lot of
[ __ ] out there man there's a lot of
mediocrity out there sometimes i just
want to get through
get through like the mediocre shows so i
can movies and i'm like no no you can't
drop them what like what
double standards
no no it's it's
it's it's it's because talking about
anime is my job right it's because like
i i need to i need to watch it in order
to have like the informed opinion that i
want to and you know sometimes there is
a certain show that gets better
i'm just surprised you can consume it at
two times sweet
why because it's like
are you a big video game guy do you play
a lot of video games uh not as much as i
used to but i do so what's the opinion
on uh escaping cutscenes
on the on your first play uh yeah
absolutely not
i skipped like old cutscenes
[Laughter]
i'm also four sectors
so you're just like boring boring i
don't want to just skip to the gameplay
yeah
that's exactly what he did you don't
know what's going on
jump jump jump a lot of the time yeah
we're gonna have our first guest
which one's worse give me the cutscenes
at least he's watching
i love the thanos stream of like when
you get to the end boss and like you
took everything from me i don't even
know who you are
that's literally him playing every
single video game
oh boy
what are some of your favorite video
games
because they keep [ __ ] talking
let me guess are you a kingdom hearts
fan
oh no really well you're a disney fan
though uh yeah but i like good games
i played
one one is bad i played chain of
memories i played two
i played three point four 358 over two
days unfortunately that one's terrible
socks here i haven't played anything
past that yeah i think they're like i
like i actually like chain of memories
really yeah that's the one that's weird
but it has like kind of deck building in
it so i i like that right right right um
but uh
and i wouldn't call myself a kingdom
hearts fan though right i didn't play
past a certain point um what are some
games that you do like them uh
i love paper mario
yeah yeah i love bioshock uh okay final
fantasy nine uh is my favorite one
uh i like seven a lot too um
i mean i grew up with a lot of nintendo
stuff so yeah mario i love i do love
good jrpgs like you know i love like
persona 5 dragon quest 11. hell yeah
i've been trying to get him to play
personally
i've i've been scared i've been scared
aren't you a voice actor why are you
skipping the cutscene i'm like hey i
just because i do it doesn't mean i want
to watch the cutscene
because a game for me is just i just
want to play
i don't wanna i don't wanna story
nonsense
connor what if everyone in the you voice
in the game is everyone's skipped all
your dialogues i wouldn't mind they have
the right they have the right to do it
you don't have the right
they have the right it's only the second
time only the second only on replays are
you allowed
that's that's uh oh boy
i i i when i stream games i try not to
do it but sometimes i have like reflex
to do it and then i'm so sorry chad i
didn't mean to do that
it's just he's not sorry he's not sorry
yeah yeah no i uh i have a let's play
channel and we're doing uh paper mario
and my co-host my good friend jay was
like skipping through the dialogue and i
was like you gotta [ __ ] stop you got
it
and we do it like months in advance and
so like when they came out all the
comments were like stop skipping through
the dialogue and i was like i was right
especially paper mario because the dye
looks so challenging i know it's so
charming right
i'm like i'm gonna kill it
i'm absolutely gonna kiss you we should
never do a let's play no no absolutely
not oh
unless like
[Music]
yeah do you find that if you're voicing
something does that enhance
the experience for you does that like
mean that you can't watch it or you
can't play it anymore like um
it doesn't really have any effect effect
for me like i actually have not played
any of the games i'm in oh really yeah
is that is that out of pure coincidence
or coincidence okay uh i think the one
that just got announced today fire
emblem warriors three hopes right that
one i probably will play because i
actually uh like you like flying i love
three houses that i'm gonna play and i
love musso games yeah um you should ask
about his fire experience
i played three houses yeah he completed
it one route well he completed one route
and then he and then he dropped it did
you watch the cutscenes
i was confused a lot of the time
you know with like because there's a
whole i'll spoil it for
three houses i'll give you like three
seconds
yeah so you know how there's like a big
betrayal yeah i was like really confused
at like one point because i was like
wait why am i fighting
because i skipped the cutscenes
i just like the strategy elements of the
the gameplay i thought that was fun so
for you they're like i just like these
non-descript anime chess pieces to move
around yep i don't know what any of them
why why they're here or what they're
doing but they go slash slash i like it
i felt like i learned the character
through the combat styles you know like
because a lot of them their combat
styles reflect their character i think
um
uh but there was also like the part when
i went to school and i was so [ __ ]
bored oh you would have hate persona 5
yeah it was like it was like i do this
amazing gameplay section where i was
like damn that was damn these guys said
these things are throwing hands dude and
then i go back to this school i gotta
talk to people for like 40 minutes and
fish that's literally
that's so [ __ ] boring why are you
making me do this let me let me just
play the gameplay you are playing the
game talking to the characters playing
the game yeah the game that's part of
the game do you like characters
or or plots i do i do see for me it's
like i love stories in movies in video
games i just want that pure gameplay
that's all i want from games he has
goopy goblin gamer brain i yeah so
that's why the majority games i play uh
like competitive games if i wasn't
streaming i wouldn't do any of these
like i would never played inscription
but i'm so glad i did inscription was so
fun
what's the description oh my god is this
amazing uh indie game by uh uh who's it
called the guys made a bunch of other
amazing guys yeah i don't remember the
names he's a really talented game dev uh
and it's
it's how would you describe description
i actually uh didn't finish it because
uh but from it's basically like an
escape room combined with like a deck
building game
like you're in like a creepiest like
cabin and you're locked in and then like
you're trying to advance through this
game of like cards like right and um
like you slowly start unlocking things
yeah yeah yeah the gameplay and the
the visual style completely changes
three times wow see i don't actually
don't know that part oh okay no that's
okay yeah yeah it's really cool is it
does it have a story oh yeah and uh i
mean i i had to read the story and i had
to pay attention
yeah
i enjoyed that story though but i think
it's good if i give it a shot i'll do it
but if i was playing it alone i wouldn't
do it and i'd have that i'd have it so
you have to force yourself to play story
based games on stream otherwise you are
going to skip the story yeah most
definitely yeah remember remember when
we were trying to get him to play 13
sentinels oh that sounds like a
nightmare that would be a nightmare oh
no i remember we we said yeah connor you
should play 13 sentinels i think on a
podcast he said yeah oh can i just skip
the cut scenes and i'm like that game is
all cut
attorney uh i have never been interested
in ace attorney i know why no yeah
the style never appealed to me
it's a good game yeah yeah i liked um or
like duncan roberts
but you skipped all the cutscenes yeah
so for you it was just like a [ __ ] it
was like a brain age game
it was a brain age game and something
there's a hat guy who goes
and you're like who's that guy what's
his deal i don't know i don't know
it's it's weird because it doesn't take
away any of my enjoyment yeah like i
still well i'm happy for you i liked
three houses i had a fun time i just
wish i could skip a lot of more stuff
easier you know
[Music]
i liked it though i love the the cool
like gameplay i'm just gonna find out oh
yeah also i i only smell food i don't
actually
what i do is i only i chew it up and
spit it out i don't swallow it i don't
know just swallow food yeah yeah yeah
i just want it i just put it in my mouth
and swallow it i don't even buy it so
why do people flavor food you know who
needs to cook chicken breast on season
when i go swimming i only put my oboz in
there
i bathe my feet and later
i don't know yeah i mean uh what are
some other games that uh i've played
that i enjoyed that i skipped all the
cartoons did you what about metal gear
revengeance because i feel like okay
that that was like you couldn't like
this it wouldn't even like even if i
wanted to i couldn't press the skip
button it was so enthralling like all
those cut scenes were just like orgasmic
that was a good game but it was like a
five-hour game it was 10 hours off slow
okay yeah but also i mean that was so
funny that was a movie that was a movie
with quick time events yeah yeah yeah so
i mean i mean that's like a lot of
kojima that's most kojima games no i
have not however you know that cutscenes
are also like little movies in a game
this was just purely a movie with
occasional button pressing it's like if
it's like if your dvd kept freezing it
well like like to me like to me when i
get to the gut like the cutscene and
everything like that like i feel like
it's
the feeling you get when you get to the
cutscene or the story portions in the
video game is like different from
watching a movie because like i feel
like i earned it you know you know like
i feel like progressing through a video
game story is so much more satisfying
than progressing through a movie story
right because like you watch a movie and
you're just there to enjoy the story
with a video game if it's like there's
immersion yeah like there's the merger
you really feel like damn i [ __ ]
earned this story man it feels good for
me it's like i don't know what it's
going on with my my brain but
if it's just like a normal game where
it's like oh if i can like one attempt
everything then i don't feel like i've
earned it i'm like yeah just did it
first time easy because because to me to
me like there are some games that i i i
have a hard time finishing games right
because i get through like the gameplay
loop i enjoy that and then it's like you
get to like that 60 to 70 percent and it
kind of i feel that yeah yeah and then
it kind of just becomes the same all
over again except you have 30 of the
game left to play right if there is not
a story i am not finishing that game or
if i'm not investing in that story there
is no way i'll like i i get that i get
that yeah and you find that with
especially a lot of jrpgs where i like
because jrpgs are so long you get to
kind of near end game and then that's
when that's when it you hit like a wall
it's also it's also that thing with
jrpgs where it's like you get to that
like 60 70 part and then you're like oh
you know you get busy or whatever right
yeah
uh these guys know but i've never played
uh like blue dragon
oh uh
a little bit but i never got far that
was i watched it i've never even played
that no what made you watch all the
cutscenes and that and not literally
every other game you've ever so you know
when you're at that age where you can
only have like three games yeah a year
and then you're like well gotta get my
mileage out so you like milked it you're
like all right i'll watch these cut
scenes
i need more hours to fill it so that i
don't have to go beg my mom for another
game